Maybelline Jade hat dieses Jahr etwas
komplett verrücktes gemacht crazy sie
haben einen Silvester Adventskalender
rausgebracht also ein Adventskalender
der nicht nur bis Weihnachten geht
sondern bis Silvester was eigentlich
ziemlich Sinn macht denn man ist ja auch
in den Tagen zwischen den Feiertagen und
Silvester irgendwie ja in so einer
feierlichen Stimmung und man arbeitet ja
auch irgendwie auf Silvester hin denn
bis dahin haben ja die meisten auch frei
ja und Silvester ist einfach auch noch
mal so ein ganz besonderer Tag oder
Abend wo Make-up natürlich mega Sinn
macht und ich freue mich ich bin
ungeschminkt also ein bisschen Make-up
drauf und habe auch einfach nichts mit
meinen Haaren gemacht außer so ein
komischer ausblockknödel da drauf ja was
soll ich euch sagen die Zeit in der ich
mich verkleide ist vorbei ja ich habe
meinen Spiegel am Start macht euch auf
eine lange Session bereit holt euch
euren Tee macht euch gemütlich denn
heute haben wir 31 Türchen se nice also
maybellineade Maybelline New York heißen
die nicht mehr maybelinade ich da jetzt
irgendwie völlig raus also ich glaube
man nennt dann auch gar nicht mehr
Adventskalender das ist dann halt ein
Silvester Countdown ist auch toll für
die die nicht Weihnachten feiern ne also
ich würde sagen die nicht Christen aber
ich glaube sehr viele nicht Christen we
feiern trotzdem Weihnachten aber ich
meine alle die die kein Weihnachten
feiern das sieht doch toll aus es war so
g toll fin wirklich sehr schön also no
joke 31 Türchen Flip aus wo geht das
alles noch hin man bekommt ihn für 70 €
31 Türchen für 70 € das ist völlig in
Ordnung also kommt drauf an was da für
Produkte drin sind da steht aber nicht
irgendwie ob das ein größeren Warenwert
oder so haben soll damit werben
Adventskalender ja eigentlich immer ganz
gerne ne Zahl 70 € bekommen für 350 €
Produkte nee wird nichts dazu gesagt 31
Make-up Highlights von Maybelline New
York in Original Größe und im Miniformat
F Beauty Überraschungen so geht der
Beauty Spaß nach dem Fest weiter
glamorösen XM und silvesterl ja seit
Jahresbeginn inszeniert sich die New
Yorker Kultmarke Maybelline neu und
tritt nun losgelöst von Jade
eigenständig als Maybelline New York auf
das ist ein Artikel von 2014 seit 2014
sag ich sicher noch Maybelline Jade okay
Maybelline New York hey das weiß ich das
das wusste ich oh mein Gott schreibt mal
in die Kommentare wer auch noch
Maybelline Jade gesagt hat ein mal
schauen was wir für ein
make-upl mal schauen was wir für ein
Make-up Look
erschaffen ich kenne diesen Concealer
und ich habe tatsächlich so einen das
ist aber 01 das ist die hellste Farbe
was soll denn eine Person machen die
eine etwas dunklere Haut hat als
[Applaus]
ich ich glaube sogar der Concealer ist
zu hell für mich es geht jetzt nicht
mehr um sehr dunkle Haut sondern also
basically fast jeder Haut die die nicht
perlweiß
ist für mich ist die Farbe super
deswegen machen doch alle Make-up Firmen
immer keinen Concealer oder Make-up oder
so rein weil es doch überhaupt keinen
Sinn macht so vielen verschiedenen
Hautfarben I don't get it wirklich vor
allem noch so bei tüche Nummer 1 man
freut sich total man hat diesen Kalender
zu Hause und dann keine Ahnung macht man
das auf und ist so geil kann ich nicht
tragen super ausgeschlossen das ist gar
nicht das hellste oh krass es gibt ja
noch viel hellere 7,43 € Nummer 2 ach
mensch wie süß eine Version von dem
colossal Mascara für den sie ja auch
sehr bekannt sind ne ja benutze ich
jetzt nicht weil ich habe so viele
Mascara wirklich ich packe euch das sehr
gerne in die verlosungsbox rein denn
sag's in jedem Video aber da hinten
sammle ich alle Produkte aus den
adventskalenderv Videos und so ungefähr
Ende November werden sie dann neu
verpackt als malw Adventskalender und
dann könnt ihr ein auf Instagram
gewinnen also folgt mir gerne auf
Instagram dort gibt's dann auch die
Infos wann es losgeht oder was ihr
machen müsst oder ja ja jetzt ist die
Frage der kolossalmascara ein Liter
kolossalmascara kostet 817 € was macht i
mit der
Info hab kein Plan ja ich habe keine
Ahnung wie viel das ist machen mal 3 €
machen mal 3 € wird hier eher so eine
schätzerei sein wir wissen dass der sich
preislich lohnt ich weiß auch nicht
warum ich immer die Preise nachgucken
muss weil ihr darauf immer besteht ihr
findet das immer ganz geil wenn ich da
auch noch mal den Preis hinterher Frage
Nummer D Türchen Nummer 3 gibt's einen
Lippen Color Sensational Lipliner uh in
sweet pink wie pragtisch dass ich nicht
geschminkt
habe wir knst bisschen erkennen ich weiß
immer nicht ob ich mir über die Lippen
malen soll oder nicht ich habe ja
eigentlich schon ziemlich große Lippen
deswegen denke ich Ruch das immer nicht
so also dien noch größeren Effekt was
soll ich zu dem sagen ich finde die
Lippenprodukte von Maybelline sind halt
echt super meisten zumindest die ich
kenne und auch dieser Stift fühlt sich
sehr gut an sag mal das ist doch eine
Originalgröße 5 € aber wisst ihr was
Maybelline ist wenigstens so eine Marke
wenn man da den Preis hört denkt man ja
okay und fällt nicht komplett ins Koma
bei irgendwelchen abstrusenpreisen habe
ich jetzt mal so gesagt Nummer 4 31
Türchen ey cool das ist wohl eine
Nagellack Base die super schnell
trocknen soll ich kenne mich nicht mit
Maybelline Nagellack aus und hab
gemachte Nägel deswegen kann ich jetzt
nicht ausprobieren was ich aber ganz
witzig finde sind diese Metallkugeln
seht ihr das und wenn man das schüttelt
also dann schütteln halt diese
Metallkugeln den Nagellack u toll 7,95
dafür sieht es aber ja bin ich ehrlich
nicht so hochwertig aus fünf uh Türchen
Nummer 5 ist ein Riesenpaket okay es ist
eine Wimpernzange na gut ich meine wie
oft wechselt man aber wie oft muss man
seine Wimpernzange wechseln ich habe die
gleiche Wimpernzange seit Jahren und ich
ma sie halt sauber und ansonsten
passiert ja nichts mit der aber
vielleicht hat jemand eine schlechtere
Wimpernzange weil das ist eine tolle
Wimpernzange mein Gott wow look at this
das Farbkonzept gefällt mir nicht ganz
so gut aber aber WoW und wie gesagt weil
ich eine Wimpernzange habe geht die an
euch die kann man nicht finden warum
kann ich sie nicht finden ja die wird
auf jeden Fall nicht verkauft mein Gott
was kostet denn so eine
durchschnittswimpernzange machen wir mal
10 € und wimpernzangen machen wirklich
ein Unterschied also falls ihr noch
keine benutzt probiert mal aus es sieht
immer ein bisschen fresher aus ich weiß
nicht aber ob der Effekt überhaupt lange
hält ich habe aber schon das Gefühl dass
es am Anfang zumindest immer sehr krass
dann
aussieht Türchen Nummer 6 oh mein Gott
dieses Video ist nicht onsert Leute wie
konnte ich euch in dem Glauben lassen
dieses Video gesponsert sein könnte
dieses Video ist und jetzt alle zusammen
nicht gesponser also ich stell es mir
mal vor wenn mich jetzt erst jemand zum
ersten Mal sieht denke ich mal was was
muss diese Person gerade denken so Info
ich mache das immer und manche Sachen
sind so tief drin da kann man nicht mehr
aufhören Nikolaus wir laufen zu unserem
Adventskalender und machen das tchen auf
und wir sind in Nikolaus Stimmung heute
ist ein ganz besonderer Tag es ist nicht
nur Naomis Geburtstag sondern auch
eine fullsiz Mascara black Drama 10 €
geht an euch ich habe genugusche ich
will jetzt mal was anderes hier gib mir
mal es ist auch so ein Verrückter
Kalender wo ab und zu mal die Zahlen
drauf stehen und manchmal das Wort mehr
Fun beim Suchen wieder der Color
Sensational Lipliner diesmal in einer
anderen Farbe den klatschen wir uns doch
glatt mal drauf ich habe nämlich nur ein
Lipliner fantastisch so ich möchte aber
hier nicht nur und Lipliner sehen das
wiederholt sich schon mir ein bisschen
zu oft der Lipliner noch mal
gekostet in Türchen Nummer 8 cheek
heat ein cream blush da lassen wir uns
natürlich nicht zweimal bitten ich hatte
dem Sephora Kalender dieses Jahr den
Benefit flüssigen Blush von dem bin ich
jetzt echt schwer begeistert aber
wahrscheinlich auch nur weil da benefit
drauf
steht okay
ich bin ein bisschen verwirrt ich sag
elich ganz ehrlich ich dachte die Farbe
so wie das aus also wie so wie die Farbe
hier ist ist auch dann im Endeffekt der
Blush vielleicht sollte es auch so
darstellen aber der ist wärmer ich finde
das ist ein ganz warmes rosa im
Gegensatz zu was drauf ist aber
toll ganz ganz super 650 na toll also
was ich besonders mochte ist dass es
sich halt wirklich bei den flüssigen von
Benefit fühlt sich das nicht so schön
zum Auftragen an so cremig und so ja wie
so ein Gel halt das ist ja nur so eine
Flüssigkeit und ich finde der hat sich
sehr gut auftragen lassen Nummer ne
Nummer ne Nummer ne neun ist das beste
Türchen denn das ist meine
Lieblingszahl da steht Tattoo Liner
drauf ist das ein Tattoo gelpencel 6 €
der ist blau wir haben blau und schlau
gelöst denn wir sind ganz schön schlau
oh will ich den benutzen ich will den
benutzen ich weiß noch nicht was man
damit wirklich so macht wisst ihr ich
mal einfach mal ich mal einfach mal
uh ja
ein blauer Stift wie findet ihr mein
Make-up Look bis
jetzt hat was oder ja also der trägt
sich halt echt super auf da ist jetzt
natürlich nicht so ein feiner Liner der
dann so Dings aber man kann was damit
machen ich sag doch bestes Türchen
Nummer 10
ich ger gehört gnier zu Maybelline oder
gehört am Ende alles einfach nur L'Oréal
die zellenreinigungswasser AllinOne
reinigt beruhigt und entfernt Make-up
für Gesicht Augen und Lippen ja also
iche benutzt das andere von G immer zum
Augen sauber machen 1,60
11 der Nagellack von l'oral überzeugt
mich irgendwie optisch gar nicht
l'oreéal habe ich gesagt ihr wisst was
ich meine fastg die Farbe ist frech
passt aber auch irgendwie zur Verpackung
von diesem Kalender also ist schon okay
5 € ich würde jetzt gerne sagen Halbzeit
aber wir haben 31 Türchen hier ist
nichts mit Halbzeit ach mensch Sky High
die berühmte Mascara ich weiß gar nicht
warum wurde sie so berühmt jeder hat sie
plötzlich benutzt also ich habe sie auch
sie ist super aber hat das ein tiktok
Trin also mittlerweile wird ein Produkt
ja wirklich nur trendt wenn es auf
tiktok verteilt wurde da machen wir 3 €
13 ist ein
Riesenpaket augenm-up
Entferner ich liebe augenm-up Entferner
ich brauche das in meinem Leben ich kann
also das ich muss es immer erstmal so
sauber machen aber was ist das denn es
hat den webe von Nagellackentferner aber
es ist soft Make-Up Entferner noch nie
gesehen dieses Produkt und ich verstehe
nicht wie sie das mit der Aufteilung
machen warum so schnell nacheinander
dann wieder eins 10 € das ist nämlich
schell fullsiz Größe fullsiz Größen sind
toll wir sind bei Türchen 14 und mein
Gesicht ist noch nicht mal ansatzweise
fertig geschminkt yes was ist das denn
infinite white color Tattoo 24
oh4 Stunden muss das cream eyesadow in
white white white white white white
white also weißer geht's
nicht jetzt habe ich Angst was habe ich
mir hier angetan
okay also es ist glaube ich dieses blau
weiß was ich jetzt an meinem Auge habe
das gibt mir ultra 90er meine Mutter
schminkt sich Weib mal was anderes ne
ich schmink mich eigentlich immer gleich
aber so weiß bin mal wirklich gespannt
wie der sich hält 7 € ich freue mich
tatsächlich über diesen weißen weil
sowas brauche ich immer für Halloween 15
uh neuen Make-up Blender kann man immer
gebrauchen der wird schmutzig dreckig
eklig matschig und dann brauch man einen
neuen ich werde i nicht anfassen obwohl
ich brauche ne ohne
Latex super vielleicht ist das eine
Produktneuheit komm kein Problem machen
wir für€ 16 fit me wer kennt nicht die
berühmte fitme Reihe ja fit me Primer
ich weiß nicht ob Primer gut sein soll
ich meine es verstopft ja wahrscheinlich
einfach die Poren was ja bei manchen
Make-up looks dann ganz schön ist dass
man ein bisschen glattere Oberfläche hat
das ist hier aber ein sicher eine
Probiergröße definitiv ich mal 2 € für
kommt jetzt brauche ich mal wieder was
ich brauch das ich war gerade sehr
verwirrt das ist drin und den hatten wir
schon warum sehen die sich so ähnlich
lash sensational full Fan effect very
black die Größe wieder nicht doch ja
hier steht sie drauf 4,5 ml hatten wir
für die anderen 3 € gemacht ne machen
wir wieder drei also immer noch kein
lippenprodukt aber schon vier Mascara
ich weiß Maybelline ist ja bekannt für
sein Mascara aber wir haben halt immer
noch kein Lippenstift drauf uh noch ein
cream Tattoo cream eyesadow in Bronze
oh ganz anderen Look bin ja Fan von
Cream Eyeshadow weil so kann man sich so
richtig schnell einfach Make-up lookuts
hinzaubern und dann hast du einfach so
zackm bisschen Schimmer D machst noch
ein bisschen Mascara deine Augenbrauen
und schon sieht aus als ob du dir
Gedanken über dein Make-up Look gemacht
hast mir stehen warme Töne auf jeden
Fall viel besser ich finde dieses
blauweiß hier ganz
furchtbar 10 € Nummer 19 wird jetzt
fantastisch Silikon
Reinigungspad nee sorry also da benutze
ich meine Hände macht ihr das mit so
einem silikoning das gebe ich euch so
nett bin ich ich glaub diese ganzen
Produkte gibt's gar nicht doch es gibt
genau das gleiche von H&M für 5 € Nummer
20 ich sehe hier gerade noch nicht mein
glamorous Silvester Look jetzt gibt noch
ein Primer hier Primer Testgröße jetzt
haben wir hier ein Primer in wohl
Originalgröße der instant Po Eraser
radiiert deine Poren Weg für 7 €
21 Color Sensational oh
wow jetzt habe ich ein in der Farbe in
derinenfbe und in einer fast identischen
Farbe shaping Lipliner
für Produkte aus und was sind die
aussuchskriterien das würde ich so gerne
mal wissen 22 danke für den nächsten
Nagellack die Farbe ich bin bei dem
nageltren jetzt nicht so am Start aber
sind diese zwei Farben irgendwie
altbacken also das sind schöne Farben
und das ist auch eine schöne Farbe aber
habe ich nicht irgendwas von glamourösen
Silvester Looks und Christmas looks
gesehen 5 € okay komm wir drehen jetzt
noch mal das Blatt um
23 der Silvester count
okay let's go
Lidschattenpinsel ja die Haare sehen
bisschen küslich aus es scheint mir so
als ob es gar keinen Maybelline Pinsel
gibt machen wir mal 4
€ es ist
Weihnachten das 24 Türchen wir gehen an
unseren Adventskalender und freuen uns
auf unser Weihnachtsgeschenk ja das
dachte ich mir doch schon noch ein
Mascara aber dieses Mal in absoluter
Originalgröße womit sie auch geworben
haben auf dem Karton der sensational Sky
High Maybelline New York Mascara den sie
s dann damit feiern die sich ab das ist
ihr neues
Lieblingsprodukt okay was kostet er
13€ 25€ es ist immer noch Weihnachten
Express brow
lich mal was anderes ja ist okay also es
macht seinen Job jetzt hier nichts neu
erfunden aber das finde ich doch gut
aber eine Probiergröße mein Gott ma wir
3 € es ist immer noch Weihnachten der
26 so weit waren wir noch nie
endlich endlich ein
Lippenstift ihr wisst nicht wie ich
darauf gewartet habe endlich nicht mehr
dieses hässlige Ding zu haben was
krümeliges ist da drauf ja die Farbe
doch die Farbe ist gut ich dachte jetzt
mal wieder altbacken aber doch die Farbe
ist ein bisschen altbacken don't steht
mir die
Farbe es ist halt ein Ton der würde
meine Mutter würde den total geil finden
aber ja ich halt nicht das ist aber
trotzdem okay ich will mich aber gar
nicht beschweren es ist ein Lippenstift
8 € so jetzt sind wir wieder auf Fahrt
jetzt gehen wir nämlich Richtung
Silvester zu und wenn man schon an
Weihnachten nicht glamorös aussah dann
jetzt wenigstens an Silvester mit einen
Liner fein soft cool Liner
Kajalstift 3€
28 jetzt werden wir richtig glamourös
ah na das ist doch mal cool
lidschattenhelfer das mache ich ganz oft
wenn ich schönen Lidschatten auftragen
möchte das sind sowieso Pflaster und die
kannst du dir dann hier unten drauf
kleben und dann kannst du so ein schönen
Lidschatten Erstellen der so schön lang
nach hinten geht dann mache ich mal 2 €
weil das ist kein Produkt was sie sonst
verkaufen 29 okay den lidschattenhelfer
für ein glamourösen Look braucht man
den
warum immer diese sa das ist do schon
wieder für eine Farbe dieses Mal
glitzert sie wenigstens da freuen wir
uns drüber dass das glitzert das passt
zu Silvester 30 boah am 30 hängt man
auch einfach durch ne da da ist passiert
nichts mehr da ist man komplett durch
mit diesem Jahr dann geht man zu seinem
silvesterkalender Lip Color Lippenstift
Entferner ah für den super stay das wäre
vielleicht mal nett gewesen wenn man den
superstay auch reingemacht hätte und
dann den superstay da rein zuun es gibt
diesen superstay Lippenstift von
Maybelline ich hole ihn mal ganz kurz
mein Knie ich wer alt das ist der
superstay Lippenstift so benutze ich
sehr gerne der superstay lebt davon dass
er ganz lange dran bleibt deswegen
superstay und Eraser also ein Radierer
dafür reinzumachen ist ja eigentlich
eine nette Sache ja aber da musst du
doch auch den superstay da drin im
Adventskalender haben sonst sagst du ja
basically hier ist schon mal der
Entferner jetzt musst du dir aber noch
den Lippenstift kaufen das finde ich ein
bisschen frech das ne nicht nur ein
bisschen das finde ich extrem frech
und wenn du deine ganzes Jahr wegradiert
hast mit dem superstay Eraser weil du
den Lippenstift nicht hattest dann gehst
du am 31 ist ist Silvester glamous time
das ist das absolute grand finale und es
ist drin der
superstay okay dann kriegt man halt den
Eraser ein Tag vorher weiß ich nicht
irwie komisch jetzt mit dem Lippenstift
Klatsch einfach drauf den superstay
hatte ich noch nicht ich habe nur diesen
anderen superstay
mat der stinkt aber auch also der riecht
ein bisschen streng finde
ich geil ich habe meine Zehner angemalt
okay 80 € gezahlt rechn mal jetzt ganz
kurz die Preise zusammen nicht schlecht
70 € gezahlt und für 180 was bekommen
ich finde das so viel Mascara drin ist
finde ich eigentlich gar nicht schlecht
weil man braucht halt das ganze Jahr
über Mascara und wenn man dann diesen
Kalender gekauft hat dann hat man
wirklich Mascara für viele Monate die
Make-up entfernt ungssachen finde ich
schlau wobei ich auch nicht checke warum
da zwei drin sind und das eine ist als
einziges Produkt von gannier ansonsten
ist alles Maybelline nur ein Garnier
Produkt also das ist mir zu random sorry
also das muss nicht drin sein ich habe
ein Problem damit dass drei lipl Liner
drin sind ganz ehrlich mach zwei
Lippenstifte und zwei passende Lipliner
dazu mit der passenden Farbe dann ist
das doch super aber nicht so random klar
man spart mega viel Geld wenn man sich
diesen Kalender kauft weil man viel mehr
Produkte bekommt als wenn man sich alles
einzeln beim dm oder so aussuchen würde
aber ich würde mir ja diese Produkte an
sich nicht alle aussuchen und das ist so
ein bisschen das Problem und drei
Lipliner finde ich wirklich ja finde ich
viel also auch wenn ich den den
furchtbar aufgetragen habe und der sich
ganz hässlich auch oben in meine Lücke
da reinrückt glaube ich kann der Spaß
machen dieser blaue Stift ein Kajal ist
immer drin ich benutze halt kein Kajal
mehr deswegen ist das halt so random für
mich ich finde den Kalender okay aber es
ging hier doch um Look für Silvester und
Weihnachten glamorous stand sogar glaube
ich auf der Seite für glamouröse xmis
und syvester Looks da hätte man ein
bisschen mehr in glamorös gehen können
ne also ich frage mich ob ob Maybelline
nicht einfach noch ein bisschen mehr
Silvester Sachen hat Highlighter z.B
wäre doch schön gewesen oder irgendwas
mit Glitzer irgendwas was einen wirklich
etwas für Silvester dann bringt wenn ihr
schon einen silvesterkalender macht dann
könnt ihr doch ein bisschen auf die
Kacke hauen über eine Sache kann ich
nicht wegkommen wenn doch alles hier
Produkte sind die jeder benutzen kann
warum zur Hölle packt man einen
Concealer als allererstes Türchen rein
warum ist dieser Concealer da drin ich
verstehe es nicht ich verstehe es nicht
ich weiß nicht ob ich irgendwie ein
Denkfehler habe oder so aber ich finde
das absolut Quatsch hätte mich nicht so
gefreut über den Kalender bin ich
ehrlich ein silvesterkalender ist
wirklich eine tolle Idee dann muss man
aber auch das Konzept durchsetzen weil
das hier ist irgendwie nichts Halbes und
nichts Ganzes und ich kriege hier
wirklich keinen glamorösen Silvester
look so wie es mir versprochen wurde
okay bis dann
tschüss